your mind it's on talk TV it's about you
and your opinions if you're thinking
about it we're talking about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I am Rosanna Lockwood uncensored tonight
are their Russian spies next door as
news emerges the three suspects are in
detention it's reported they have led
Suburban lives in the UK for years
taking cake to neighbors and working as
a hospital driver do spies live among us
and what dangers do they pose
Donald Trump vows he'll never surrender
as he's charged again over illegally
trying to overturn the 2020 presidential
election will examine why this is the
most frightening case yet for the former
president
and it's one of the oldest rivalries in
sporting history can the lionesses heal
the Heartbreak left after the ashes
football stars from England and
Australia joining live will be going
Head to Head
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored with
Rosanna Lockwood good evening and
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored with
me Rosanna Locker back in the chair
tonight for peers now spice they walk
among us always have done always will
part of the bargain is understanding
that we have our own British spies
walking elsewhere too and the other part
is staying on top of the threat the
classic game of cat and mouse it is down
to our intelligent services to make sure
they spot the spies operating here and
prevent their activities from tipping
over into real world danger as much as
they can we're of course talking about
here MI5 MI6 dchq and counter-terrorism
police and that's why this evening I tip
my hat to all those involved in the
investigation and Detention of three
suspected spies in the UK alleged to be
working for the Russian security
Services now these suspects are
allegedly Bulgarian Nationals they've
lived and worked here in the UK for many
years they were actually detained back
in February along with another two
suspects investigations like these
necessarily take place beyond our view
sometimes the whole criminal trial
process actually happens in secret
behind closed Jaws due to National
reasons of security it's the official
Secrets act in my mind that's an
arrangement worth having in a country
like ours that has been host of some
really truly horrendous Russian
intelligence operations they go back to
the height of the Cold War let's remind
ourselves in the 1950s and 1960s a
number of British Nationals worked
undercover for the Soviets the most
infamous was the Portland five who were
later uncovered by MI5
the 90 Soviet diplomats were expelled
from the UK in 1971 after they were
accused of spying for the Kremlin in
recent times 2006 former Russian spy
Alexander litwinenko a fierce critic of
Vladimir Putin was murdered after his
cup of tea was laced with a radioactive
substance and in 2018 just a few years
ago former Russian double agent Sergio
scrapal and his daughter Yulia were
poisoned by the nerve agent novichok in
Salisbury now on those most recent
occasions of fresh in our minds it felt
a little bit like we weren't ahead of
the threat that it's got to the point of
Russian operatives carrying out lethal
poisonings on our streets but today's
revelation
about these suspects for whatever reason
revealed to us now even though they've
been detained for six months at this
point it does seem to confirm there's
more going on behind the scenes than we
necessarily realize and that off our
authorities they're not asleep at the
wheel
and in a world filled with continuous
threats from Bad murderous actors like
Vladimir Putin that's something I like
to be reminded of now joining us to
discuss all of this is the American
investor and art critic of Vladimir
Putin Bill Browder and former MI5
intelligence officer and whistleblower
Annie Marshall great to have you both
with us um bill I will come to you first
um you've made it your latter life's
work speaking out against the Kremlin
the bad actions of the Kremlin murderous
actions at this point
um tell us your reaction to the news
today
well um my first reaction is if they've
caught three there's probably 150 that
they haven't caught I mean the Russians
have a very very active intelligence
gathering operation uh in the UK
um in addition to the official people
who are in the embassy there are these
unofficials like these characters that
have been uh arrested or arrested back
in February
um uh the other thing I would say is is
that it's not just these people that are
doing Putin's Dirty Work in the UK
um I've been a victim myself of Russian
oligarchs who are asked by Putin to do
things those oligarchs then hire British
lawyers British private investigators
British PR firms to carry out the
kremlin's wishes
um when you say we haven't been asleep
at the wheel because we caught these
people we these people have been active
in the UK for 10 years and I believe
that that a big reason why
um all these things are happening is
because there's so much Russian money
flowing into the UK that nobody really
wanted to say say a word otherwise and
and that's why we're in this situation
yeah I mean you bring up the important
point that there are
doctors that are hiding that our
intelligence agencies are looking for
and spotting I said that they did well
in this case you disagree with me but
also Those Who hide in plain sight and
this is the very relevant point of
Russian interference Russian funding
Russian money that comes into the United
Kingdom specifically London as well I
know this is a point that you are
particularly concerned about because
it's often the people that we're looking
at day to day it's newspaper owners it's
people in the House of Lords it's it's
everywhere the scale of Russian
influence in the United Kingdom it's
something quite shocking and do you
think that has changed at all since the
onset of well I'm going to call the
renewed invasion of Ukraine
indeed there's no there's no question
that that the um the whole mood has
changed in the UK since February 2022
when when this terrible murderous War
has started and things are completely
different now than they were before but
the trouble is that they had the
Russians had like
um 20 years to get their claws into us
and they're they're everywhere I mean
and just you mentioned uh the House of
Lords
um Alexander lebedev who was a former
KGB agent who became extremely wealthy
from his contacts in the Russian
government
um his son came to the UK spending his
money to buy a newspaper he naturalized
and then he became a member of the House
of Lords I mean you have a direct
hereditary connection to the Russian
Security Services in the House of Lords
it doesn't get much more
clearer than that I mean that's that
that's right out in the open right there
for all of us to see and nobody said a
word about it it's pretty plain sight
isn't it bill I want to talk a little
bit about your experience as well with
living alongside these threats because
you have taken on the Kremlin very
forthrightly you say there have been
threats to your life just talk to us a
little bit about that what that feels
like day to day
well my my main goal has been to get um
the Russian government officials
connected to Putin sanctioned have their
assets Frozen and their visas canceled
under something called the magnitsky ACT
Putin hates my guts for the magnitsky
ACT has now been passed in the UK and 34
other countries and he's been going
after me with death threats kidnapping
threats eight Interpol arrest warrants
lawsuits all sorts of other stuff and
there's all sorts of people involved in
all these things in the west being paid
for by the Russians and so I'm
constantly having to effectively look
over my shoulders not just for Russians
but for Western enablers who have been
hired by the Russians to be um working
for Putin that's very ugly it is very
ugly and that's something I just want to
discuss you before we go across to Annie
to get a bit of the intelligence officer
side of things but in terms of the
ugliness of it bill it's something I I'm
also Keen to remind people of viewers to
this program colleagues and everything
else that sometimes when it comes to spy
stories people get a bit caught up and
think oh it's terribly sexy and
interesting because obviously we know
what Hollywood does with spy stories but
the real reality of it like we saw in
Salisbury is very Grim indeed isn't it
and it is grim indeed and and um it's
not just Salisbury we've seen poisonings
taking place all over Europe um we of
course there was the lit finenko that
you mentioned in the introduction where
with uh polonium 210 and and there are
people all over
um enemies of Putin who have been
poisoned
um shot
um you know all sorts of other
situations by people agents working for
the Russian government this is not just
some kind of like high level stuff this
is you know on the street you know life
and death type of stuff and and it puts
everybody at risk and it's something
which absolutely had to be exposed and
stopped Bill thank you let's cross over
to Annie now Annie you and I have spoken
in the past I think in different
settings and different occasions and I
want to remind you is that you were a
former MI5 intelligence officer you've
turned almost whistleblower now I think
it's fair to say you've talked more
about the agency and the type of
operations that they carry out so when
you saw this news today perhaps you saw
it before we did or you knew about it
before uh what did you think about it do
you think
um it we're receiving the information
exactly as it is
um I have to say a slightly flummoxed
when I first read the story because
these people sound so low down the
pegging order
um I was thinking well what sort of
access would they have but um Bill
alluded to this before very briefly in
the sense there is a sort of hierarchy
when it comes to intelligence work so um
in terms of the Intelligence Officers
who work for organizations like the FSB
and the svr they would come into the UK
under diplomatic cover be based in
somewhere like the embassy or perhaps a
trade delegation and they are the
Intelligence Officers trying to gather
um secrets from the UK um sending them
back to Russia in terms of the people
who were arrested and alleged to have
been in possession of um interesting
documents these would be termed illegals
so you know you mentioned a couple of
the old spy rings in UK history they
tend to be people who are placed in the
local community they may be undercover
for years and then activated when needed
or indeed they may not have been
allegedly may not have been part of
aspiring but became active much more
recently but illegals don't have
diplomatic immunity like the
Intelligence Officers do who are based
out of the embassy so they can be
prosecuted and I think that's what's
happened in this case I mean just to go
back to more recent UK history as well
when it comes to other illegals in 1998
a woman called Melita Norwood who became
known in the media as the granny spy I
don't know if you remember this case was
outed as someone who had passed the
National Security secrets to the
Russians for decades and more recently
but in the U.S there was of course the
American
um aspiring in 2010 of whom one of the
members was someone who became known as
the Glamorous spy Anna Chapman and they
were illegals they could have been
prosecuted but they're involved in a
spice war and sent back to Russia so
this thing you know these sort of
approaches do go on fairly routinely and
even though the access the apparent
access of these three um suspects and
they haven't yet been convicted
obviously they're in a sentence or
proven guilty
um but the access of these three
suspects perhaps is less relevant than
the fact that they happen to be EU
Nationals so freedom of movement before
brexit and also they could have just
been part of a sort of an undercover
cell that provided low-level support to
others who are more active within the
intelligence
thanks Annie I think our viewers would
be interested to know and not I'm
stressing not in specific relation to
this case in these suspects again
ongoing case uh innocent to approve him
guilty but some of the previous examples
you've highlighted as well why people
choose to go and work for other
governments obviously Bulgaria and
Russia have a long Soviet history behind
them but you say that these people don't
have the Diplomatic Immunity afforded to
people who might be in the diploma
diplomatic residence of their country
it's enormously risky what leads people
I know there's not one set answer but to
do this
it's a very complex answer
um in terms of trying to recruit agents
in the field
um most Intelligence Officers use an
acronym which is mice so that means and
how to motivate someone to do precisely
what we're discussing here which is take
a huge risk and potentially betray um
people family friends that they might
work with so my stands for money
ideology compromise and ego and in most
cases the most willing agents and
illegals would be the most willing
people because they volunteer to go and
do this sort of thing would probably not
be hugely motivated by money although
that will help
um probably not compromise because you
know they make a very unwilling
employees but ego certainly the idea
that you're working in the shadows
you're doing something secret you are
potentially doing something that's good
for your country's longer term interests
or you might have relatives in who are
Russian so you're doing something in the
interest you think of Russia so that
would be the ideological side of things
so I think with illegals generally you
appeal to the ego and you appeal to the
ideological function and then obviously
there's sort of financial incentive
thrown in on top of that so that would
be how these people could be recruited
and sent in but to live a very secret
life for 10 years and a fairly hum drum
one as well you mentioned in your intro
that you know spies are always
glamorized in the media and they are but
a lot of these sort of undercover
aspirings the illegals live very hung
looking lives as these three apparently
did
um in the suburbs doing routine jobs but
you know by night they're doing a very
secret job a very secret role so it's a
weird combination it certainly is but it
is absolutely fascinating getting your
expertise and specialism on this Annie
and Bill thank you very much for joining
us
uncensored next to Nike we're going to
be playing you a damning phone call from
former president Donald Trump that will
form a central part of this latest
criminal case against him coming up next
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored and then
there were four Donald Trump is facing a
fourth indictment this time in Georgia
he denies all 13 charges against him in
it which accuse him of trying to engage
in a conspiracy to steal votes to
overturn the 2020 presidential election
now this phone call between the former
president and Georgia's Secretary of
State Brad raffensberger will form a key
part of the criminal case I just want to
find
uh uh 11 780
votes which is one more that we have
because we want to say I only need 11
000 votes fellas I need 11 000 votes
give me a break there's nothing wrong
with saying that you know uh
that you've recalculated well Mr
President the challenge that you have is
the data you have is wrong by joining me
now to discuss all things Trump and the
latest indictment the host of out kicks
Tommy Lauren is fearless Tommy Lauren
joins us good friend of the show also
with us Donald Trump's former lawyer one
of them Timothy politori and former
Republican congressman and fast becoming
friend of the show Joe Walsh given the
amount of news we've had lately all
three of you it's fantastic uh for you
to join us thank you for making time and
a busy busy time for you all uh I'll
start with you though Timothy bringing
the legal uh mind to this
um and if you could explain to our
International audience exactly what's
going on here in this fourth indictment
because what we've got is Rico charges
which maybe a British audience aren't
familiar with and some are saying could
be incredibly serious for Trump
Rico stands for racketeering influence
and corrupt organizations it's a statute
that was intended to go after organized
crime figures I've I've defended a lot
of these cases back earlier in my career
doing
um you know so-called Mafia cases and
reading this indictment it certainly is
something where they can take you know
disparate uh separate criminal acts and
you know bundle them together to
increase the sentencing exposure however
based on my reading of this indictment I
think that they've really missed the
mark and are trying to misuse this
statute because ultimately Fannie Willis
is just a County prosecutor she only has
a very limited jurisdiction and so she's
trying to use this statute to go beyond
what she's allowed to do within her
County and I think before you even get
to the merits of the case structurally
it's a mess and I think it's probably
going to get dismissed just based on
legal grounds and conversely some might
say because it's a local situation as
you said you've got this local judge
it's in Georgia rather than anything
sort of doj or federal
it actually could be more powerful some
are saying because it means that Trump
can't pardon himself when he becomes
president is that true
it is true that he can't pardon himself
a state conviction can be pardoned by
the governor as opposed to the president
um but another piece of this you know
when we talk about the local judge
because it is a local prosecutor
charging a federal official the former
president as well as Mark Meadows with
State crimes this case will likely be
taken out of the state court and
actually moved to the federal court
very much for uh clarifying for us I'm
going to come back to you and talk a
little bit more about your experience
working with Trump and the legal team
but Tommy I want to come to you on that
point of Rico racketeering criminal acts
as Timothy was saying that she often
using kind of gangster and mobster
trials some are saying you know Trump's
been often describing Bob so now he
really truly is going to be one
foreign
yeah gonna be gonna be one in the court
of public opinion but when you look at
this indictment once again it reads like
a Witch Hunt just like indictments one
through three I mean this is political
interference and make no mistake the
timeline on this was manipulated the
timeline on this was very specific they
want Donald Trump to be marred into
legal Battles Through the primaries
through the general election they also
want to bait Trump supporters into
supporting Donald Trump knowing that at
least on one of these they're probably
going to get some kind of a conviction
even if it does go on appeal they want
to Mar him they want to destroy him they
want to run him dry with legal bills and
legal fees and this whole Rico thing you
know they indicted several others in
this same instance in Georgia because I
think they want to get the others to
speak out against Donald Trump's to say
to save their own tale which
strategically is probably great for them
it's horrible for the country and it's
only going to solidify Donald Trump's
Mega base unfortunately it's going to
have larger implications for a general
election the Democrats in this country
three are evil but they are not stupid
so congratulations to them they have
manipulated the American people in the
election process once again tell me I
want to ask you whether just the volume
of these cases because as you said there
you know it's just ever increasing
you're saying that's going to cause the
bass to Double Down does it not cause
you to just rethink your position
slightly if more and more judges more
and more courtrooms more and more States
come forward as they can continue to
keep doing otherwise you have any faith
in your justice system at all
well Hey listen there's a lot of
Americans that are very frustrated with
our justice system our two-tiered system
of justice and it's quite obvious and I
think that that's the exact approach
that the Democrats are taking they think
if they charge him with enough things in
enough places enough times that somehow
that will make his base fall away and
believe that he is a crook or a criminal
but these cases all of them one through
four are ridiculous they are
structurally unsound so if you look at
this as somebody who doesn't pay
attention who just wants to believe
Trump is a crook then you might fall for
it but those of us that are paying
attention know that this is a political
Witch Hunt and we the American people
would like to decide the 2024 election
we would not like it to be taken out of
our hands once again and this is just
another way around that another way
around the will of the American people
it's a farce it's a Witch Hunt and
Donald Trump is very used to at this
point I mean impeachment one impeachment
two then you go after him indictment one
indictment two indictment three and
Diamond four I mean at what point are
they just gonna face this man fair and
square they're scared to and that's the
problem uh Tommy thanks there's ever a
few point of view coming to Joe who's
been sitting patiently there and Joe and
I
think about that as Tommy pointed out
impeachment one two indictment one two
three four that to me just says guilty
guilty guilty guiltier to other people
um like Tommy and to other Trump
followers and supporters they just think
it means he's being attacked more
I I disagree vehemently with Tommy on
sort of the legal aspect of this but I
agree with her on the politics look this
is another indictment where there's
credible evidence that Donald Trump
committed crimes to try to overturn the
2020 election
um and that will be pursued but as to
the politics Tommy's right this is going
to strengthen Donald Trump politically
not just with his base I've heard from
Plenty of Republicans who are not big my
God Trump worshipers and they're pissed
off about this they think it looks like
it's Democratic piling on so I think
this will help Trump politically Beyond
his base
and I should clarify when I say it makes
me think guilty guilty guilty guilt yeah
that's just my interpretation of the way
I'm seeing it all playing out of course
everyone is innocent until proven guilty
in a court and Trump uh is owed his
trials and he will get them
um and I also want to ask you Joe about
the way that Republicans are handling
this because we've heard your point of
view there about the sort of democratic
pylon as it's been called and the
governor of Georgia is a republican now
Trump released a statement on his
platform truth social uh today where he
talked about the sort of evidence he's
been collecting with regards to the way
that the Georgia boat was handled and he
said there's big Revelations coming the
governor of Georgia has tweeted as a
response uh basically saying this was
not a stolen election and talking out
against Trump more and more Republicans
really coming out here I mean does he
have many any people in the party behind
him
well I I guess I don't see more and more
Republicans coming out against Trump
good for Brian Kemp for saying what he
said Kemp's a good man but Brian Kemp
isn't running for president against
Donald Trump all you have to do right
now is look at all of Trump's Republican
Challengers and all of Trump's serious
Republican Challengers are going to Echo
his claims that Tommy's claims that this
is a political Witch Hunt there is no
anti-trump Lane in this Republican party
so if you come out now if you're
DeSantis or Nikki Haley or Tim Scott and
you come out and you condemn Donald
Trump you're done politically in this
Republican party they all know that uh
and so they're going to defend Trump and
hope that something happens to Donald
Trump but that's all they're going to do
tell me do you think that's a fair
assessment they're waiting for something
to happen a bolt of lightning and
they've got no other option
Hey listen I agree with Joe that any
other Republican they cannot come out
against Donald Trump they cannot come
out for what's happening to him what
they can do however is they can say
listen I think what's happening to
Donald Trump as a political Witch Hunt
and it's a political persecution however
I do believe that I am the candidate
that can take us to the White House
because of this mess I can get into the
White House I can change things I can
clean up this system this unfair
two-tiered system of justice that is
going to be the lane that other
Republicans are going to have to take if
they want to be the nominee or have any
chance of being the nominee but to come
out and say hey what's happening to
Donald Trump is fair and just yeah
there's just no way there's a pathway
for them to reach a nomination or have
any future in the Republican party to be
quite honest with you tell me before I
know you've got to rush off somewhere
it's a really busy day for you but
before you go I just want to ask you
what is it about Donald Trump that
captures you so much what it is about
him as a person or him as a leader that
makes you want to defend him against
everything
well listen he had a great presidency
and I can look at that as a trump
supporter but I can just look at that as
an everyday average American who did
very well under Trump policies securing
our border or doing the best he could to
secure our border on our economy our
trade deals I mean the man did great
things for this country so I support him
for that reason and I don't believe that
they should be attacking him piling on
him just because they're scared to
confront him head to head in a fair
election so that's why I continue to
support Donald Trump I also am a big
supporter of Governor Ron DeSantis but
more than anything I'm America first and
I want to see my country succeed Tommy
thanks as ever for your insights I want
to head back to Timothy now um because
Timothy when you were part of Trump's
legal team you actually stood down as
one of his attorneys you were part of
this Mar-A-Lago documents case you said
the reason you stood down wasn't
anything to do with the actual merits of
the case itself but more to do with the
kind of disputes from inside the legal
team is that true and and what do you
think is happening in the Trump legal
team I'm going to say teams plural given
the amount of criminal charges he's
facing at the moment
well I so I handle both the Mar-A-Lago
case as well as the January 6 case yeah
I was on both of the federal
investigations at the time and you know
I chose to step down just because uh not
it wasn't anything to do with the client
it wasn't anything to do with the case
it was some of the people around the
client that made it impossible for me to
do my job the way that I thought uh
should be done and so that's that's why
I stepped down
um now I don't talk about it you know as
much anymore
um and you know I I do see that you know
some of these same individuals are still
around uh some are named as unindicted
co-conspirators and
um or at least one person in particular
his name is an unindicted co-conspirator
in these two new indictments so it's
it's problematic when you have people
around you that are not necessarily
doing everything uh to help you win
you've been clear about what you've seen
think about this current Georgia and
Diamond the fourth one but do you think
there are merits to any of the legal
cases bought against Trump
I'm sorry can you say that again do you
think there are merits to any of the
legal cases currently bought against
Trump you've been clear about what you
think about this latest fourth
indictment of Georgia
so I mean look there are issues here
um and I I I stay away from the politics
side of things I'm just a lawyer and
whether it was a good idea to uh to do
certain things is different from whether
somebody should go to jail everything
that I have seen uh indicates that when
it comes to the actual facts here that
there was no corrupt intent uh that
these things you know had different
explanations than the prosecutors trying
to put out and so I don't think that any
of these cases should correctly and
justly result in a conviction now given
the volume of the cases and the various
jury pools that they may uh be seeing I
think that some of them could
potentially you know get to a verdict
are they going to eventually going to be
able to withstand an appeal going all
the way to the Supreme Court perhaps not
uh it's definitely complicated I mean if
you just sit there and look at the
volume of it and you say okay you have
these four cases 90 some counts it seems
overwhelming but you got to remember
that in trial you're going to cut those
up into pieces and you just take them
one piece at a time and each one of
these charges individually in my opinion
is winnable
interesting stuff look Joe and Timothy
we've just run out of time but thank you
both very much for joining us today
uncensored next tonight as police Chiefs
call for parents with Tick-Tock jobs to
be fined over morally apparent Behavior
we ask who's responsible plus Piers
Morgan and sent it has been nominated
for a national television award I'll
tell you how you can vote for the big
man next
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King q
that figure is only one for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail not working just because
their skin fault don't mean they're
Kinfolk do you believe you can win this
war maybe we cry again they're trying to
force you out yes I feel betrayed keep
it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for what appears to be
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
foreign
[Music]
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know you're probably going to
whoop me off shorts
some of them they're easily lit
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you that
you'd be worried about so are you saying
that you're being overwhelmed that
you're inundated we are really working
hard for you we're just asking patients
to be patient with us what does a woman
make
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drugs you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
this is talk TV
foreign
contributor Paul larone Adrian political
journalist Ava Santina and former
newspaper editor Emily Sheffield also
joining us in the studio it's an old
women thing
I would like to say I didn't plan it
that way but of course I did thank you
very much
um no we do have some big brains here
from the worlds of legal from the worlds
of Journalism so I want to discuss some
serious stories before we get to the fun
stuff regards ntas uh specifically the
Met police now this came up today not
only because it's in the news but also
because I started the show by sort of
commending
um counterterrorism officers from the
Met police for the work they've done and
uncovering some suspected Russian spies
at the moment you know and everything
else and I was thinking about that but
then this news came out this afternoon
about WhatsApp messages among police
officers and it reminded me that the Met
police are under just such a huge amount
of scrutiny at the moment and some would
say quite justifiably so this latest
news story six former met police
officers have been charged with sending
racist messages on Whatsapp after a news
night investigation that's by the BBC
they're going to be in court on the 7th
of September some really hideous
allegations about jokes made about the
Rwanda policy flooding in Pakistan Etc
the officers served in different parts
of the force but coming to the panel on
this you know is just a reminder of what
some are saying you know we hear ever
more calls to disband the Met Paula do
you think this will only add to that
obviously I mean it's going to add
because of course there are lots of
people on the street who come into
contact with the police on a daily basis
who will tell you that they are facing
racism and that they are facing racism
because of not only the racist police
officer but the structure the
institution that is the Met police and
this isn't just a problem within this in
in this country I think they've got the
same similar issue at the moment in
Northern California similar case where
they've got about 12 officers
um who are being investigated for racial
text messages Etc and what we have to
focus on is not just that we've
discovered these racist officers and the
text messages but we're also going to
have to go back over all their
investigations and all that part that
they played in investigations to
understand what motivated them and was
it racism in terms of any investigations
that they were involved in so it's not
just about the text messages which are
damning in itself but it's what part it
played in any investigations that they
undertook this is a big job for the met
and I'm not sure that the Met are really
the people who are going to be able to
deal with it themselves this is an
outside task I think who's going to have
to come in and deal with this yeah it's
a really interesting point to raise
because they are retired offices all six
of them between 2001 and 2015. so that
means I don't know we don't know the
dates of each we haven't given enough
information none of us um in the Press
have been allowed to see any of the
whatsapps that they sound horrific
it was a private group amongst retired
officers the BBC is saying that they
understand that there was a still
serving officer in there
[Music]
I I've got two thoughts about this and
as the formatters of the evening
standard we used to cover the met I
still think the Met's too big and needs
to be broken up I think it covers too
large an area there is too much that has
gone wrong with it and it's unable to
believe itself I'm afraid I don't even
think that the current I don't even
think Rowley can be trusted to reform
the Met because I think he's still part
of the Met he's still part of the force
that clearly has some serious leadership
problems to be discounted the report
yeah he said it wasn't institutionalized
racism I believe there is some
institutionalized racism I don't believe
it's there in every single officer or
anything like that completely unfair to
put that across officers but I think
your Point's really interesting is that
if you discover that police office and
you're the first one I've heard mention
this
are racist
and they have gone they have served for
a long time in that police force do you
need to go back and look at the cases
that they were working on I mean it's
literally just the tip of the iceberg
but that I don't think the police can do
because you know we're about to talk
about another case here the police have
another very serious problems they are
underfunded there aren't enough offices
on the beat we have got current rape
cases going on which are not being
investigated they're not being
prosecuted so I have a fear is what onus
how much time has been taken up like
getting these six officers retired for
racist comments retired offices on a
private WhatsApp group that's going to
go to court what about women who are not
getting their rape cases to court not
getting it and I want to bring over and
on well that's what we don't know
there's there's the women not getting
their rate Coast in court but there is
also uh an addition to this uh claims
that the Met is failing to investigate
this homophobic attack absolutely
horrendous attack that happened here in
London uh over the weekend a place
called Clapham uh a gay Pub
um the two Brewers two men was stabbed
in what is being called a homophobic
attack the victim who wants to remain
anonymous said he was punching a face in
this random attack a picture has been
released of the supposed attacker now
but today Ava claims that the Met police
didn't take warning seriously enough and
didn't investigate enough either yeah I
mean it has quite horrendous sort of
like flashbacks to the Wayne cousins
incident wasn't it when we knew that he
had been flashing or he had been
reported to be flashing at the time and
then no one had investigated it what I
don't really understand is there doesn't
it's kind of almost acting like an a e
Department in the NHS sort of only
acting when something becomes an
emergency we're not actually looking at
any kind of treatment or any kind of you
know events that may eventually lead to
a crime what I don't understand I mean
just today I I live in central London
and I was looking outside and there were
two young boys about 14 being arrested
or they looked like they were being
arrested because they had been smoking
well they've been smoking marijuana I
could smell it and um you know that's
you know whatever why on Earth did it
take six police officers to look after
that event and you go well where on
Earth are you you know on a day to day
why aren't you in Clapham investigating
a homophobic attack why aren't you
looking at the guy who's just nicked
someone's phone 200 meters away I don't
know what they're doing who's running
this but the whole thing needs to be
looked at whilst we're on the topic of
Law and Order Emily I'll come back to
you because I believe you've got teenage
sons and the story of what we're called
Tick-Tock yobs
um but this is the prime minister Rishi
sunax blasted the organizing on social
media of looting and disruption as
appalling and unacceptable
[Music]
I know
now this is the idea that Tick Tock is
being used on other social media
platforms to encourage teenagers or
their advertising kind of criminal
activities and Richie sunac was it's a
stock prime minister but what's he gonna
do to stop it
that you could crack down further on the
social media platforms so I think to be
fair they don't want to host this type
of content oh I totally describe why are
they cracking down on it fast enough and
firmly enough and I would say no because
we're seeing it proliferate and if I've
seen the pictures of the crowd outside
selfridges that those adverts going out
for people to go there that went viral
that must have been running for long
enough that they could have taken it
down and they could track the people who
are reposting and posting they should be
banned from those accounts immediately
for lifetime of tick tock yeah but
there's no legislation for them to act
under if you look at the Online safety
bill that was going to be brought in it
was totally inadequate for the last
decade social media companies in this
country have been allowed to run riots
over the market okay they have been
allowed to act in whatever the way that
they please they haven't had to pay as
much taxes they should you know they
should need to and frankly ministers Don
don't actually understand how the social
media works and so they can't actually
put together the legislative framework
in order to tackle it no no but I think
there's a there's a there is a there's a
there's a bigger problem here we can't
just keep legislating for every single
tiny event there is there is legislation
that should deal with that already it's
incitement to violence to Crime there's
legislation
accounts but Emily this isn't this isn't
about over legislating which I would
agree with you this government has
actually been incredibly good at over
legislating what this is about is
sending a very clear message to social
media companies that this type of
behavior behavior is not to be tolerated
they have tolerated this Behavior they
have actually supported this behavior
and I'm surprised that Richie sunac
feels more comfortable pointing the
finger at harangued and harassed and
beleaguered parents who are working two
jobs who would love to be able to sit at
home with their Darlings but basically
can't afford to who have to be reminded
that there are no youth clubs there are
no youth workers we were told by I the
local government Association that
apparently 88 of local Authority funding
in relation to Youth and youth clubs Etc
has been cut since covid um
I'm really sorry though just because
there isn't a youth club for a 16 year
old to hang out does not mean they go
and start robbing a store on selfridges
I'm sorry there's not enough to do in
the holidays it's okay to go and rob a
store yes
why let me explain to you why when
before we had social media my mum had to
deal with myself and my sister at home
getting up to mischief
now I have to deal with not only my
children and and and and
you know the next door neighbors I also
have to deal with three thousand four
thousand other naughty children who will
engage my child and I am lucky I can be
at home in the summer holidays I am
lucky I still have a certain level of
control over my children not every
parent is lucky and that is why it makes
a difference
all of you thank you fascinating
discussion we're straight out of time on
that one we will be back with
information about the ntas as well but
on uncensored next tonight Peters has
made himself Public Enemy Number One in
Australia recently do you remember that
because it was criticism about the ashes
now the lionesses are getting similar
treatment from some of the newspapers
down under I'll be talking to two
football styles from both sides as the
Rivalry heats up
[Music]
laughs
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
coming up on the talk Norfolk and
Suffolk Police apologize after a
thousand victims and Witnesses details
are leaked former U.S president Donald
Trump faces fresh criminal charges for
trying to overturn the 2020 election and
the start of Snow White reboot is
slammed for calling Prince Charming a
stalker we're discussing all that at
nine o'clock
[Music]
welcome back to bismorgan uncensored you
know who's been nominated in the TV
interview category at this year's nta's
National Television Awards our very own
Piers Morgan of course he has been
shortlisted and you know who hasn't been
shortlisted I want to mention this on
peers as well Prince Harry who gave an
interview to Tom bradby that didn't make
it off the long list into the shortlist
also that controversial docu-series how
Harry and Megan which was on Netflix
that hasn't been shortlisted either I
say this all for peers is benefit
because of course Piers has been
shortlisted and let's remind ourselves
why
Prime Minister President Trump Mr
President first lady Stormy Daniels
Jordan Peterson welcome to all these
people protesting just don't get it any
of them don't it's not slightly
patronizing
when you're going through the treatments
you have some tears God I'm such a softy
I'm not a performing monkey come on
Brian and it's something that really
hurt me because they doubt of my words
a woman is me a woman is somebody whose
breasts hang down to her stomach thought
the marginalized we're supposed to have
the boys I've been a terrible liar
you're being a Karen pass Morgan
kiss condoms to kiss caskets will get
you coming and we'll get you going I
think it's only room for one king man
now I'm saying
oh look at that it's great how can you
not vote let's remind you how you can
using the QR code that we just showed
you on the screen here it is again now
you can obviously go to the NTA website
as well but if you scan this you can
vote for peers voting is open you have
until midday on Tuesday the 5th of
September to have your say but obviously
stick a vote in for peers get him
another gong for his dressing groom he
loves it
now talking of gongs talking about
sporting events it's the game we've been
waiting for tomorrow the lionesses face
the matildas it's the Women's World Cup
semi-final Australian newspapers have
been taking swipes to England look at
this front page of Monday's Australian
Daily Telegraph reading now for the
poems the sporting rivalry between
England and Australia does of course Run
Deep this Summer's battle for the men's
ashes it was marred by those accusations
of unsportsmanlike conduct controversial
stumpings even I sort of began to follow
quick and I never do and the change of
ball on the fourth afternoon of the
final rest you can tell final test you
can tell that was scripted not from my
head because I don't know anything about
Cricket but I did follow Piers outrage
on it Fizz was targeted by the Aussie
newspapers for the outrage accused of
being a crybaby so who will come out on
top to my how they deal with all this
rivalry intention is it all just silly
nonsense I'm joined from Sydney by the
Australian Aston Villa footballer Emily
gilnick and by the former English
lioness Leanne Sanderson ladies thank
you so much for making time on this big
Eve ahead of this big event Emily I'll
come to you first given that you're the
host or the co-host this year in
Australia and I hear that the atmosphere
down there has been absolutely uh
stunning
how much pressure are the Australian
side going to be under then to perform
yeah look it's always massive pressure
when you're at a World Cup let alone a
home World Cup I think this year for us
the the magnitude of of this event has
been bigger than we ever expected
um so yeah there is a lot of pressure
but at the end of the day you'd much
rather in your backyard than in England
so you know we'll take that pressure
with open arms okay Leanne coming to you
I mean not at all biased in this but I
am of course English and I do love the
lionesses
um but dealing with that pressure then
having that home side in Australia
really cheering and Matilda's on how the
Lioness is going to deal with that
I think you know we've shown how
impactful the fans can be in last Euro
summer you know when we won the Euros I
think it was amazing and I think having
that home full advantage really does
help but I think these lionesses are
ready I think the Matilda's have had a
really good tournament so far and I
think having the fans on their side will
certainly help we saw England in the
last game against Colombia most of the
fans inside the State stadium were
Colombian and it was very hostile and I
think the lionesses now have learned to
be resilient and they've become a bit of
a mentality beast but one thing I will
say is the only team that have beaten us
under Serene of England have been
Australia so you know having that in
their back pocket might help I think
it's been a fantastic tournament so far
in Australia have really put these
players I'm not sure have really put
themselves on the map because similar to
how the lionesses were last summer no
one was really looking up nobody was
really respecting the sport and now
everybody's looking up and now
everybody's respected and it's great to
see that's great that you think there's
been that sea change in a year Emily do
you agree with that we've been debating
on the show over the last week or so
where there has been a sea change give
people all respecting the sport as it
should be
yeah absolutely I mean when I played for
Aston Villa and I was in England I was
actually at the Euro final I saw what it
did for a nation there and I saw what it
did for women's football particularly
with the crowd attendance that we had
later that season so I'm hoping
Australia has the same shift because to
be honest women's football and football
alone in Australia has been at the lower
end of the pecking order so I'd like to
see it you know to see it get up right
up there because we've got AFL and rugby
um over here not sure if you guys are
too familiar with AFL
um but it's really the sport of
Australia so you know this world cup
needs to be the Turning Point a major
change needs to happen with this board
and look Emily Leanne was just talking
there about the hostility that there
could be in the stadium tomorrow against
the England players do you think it will
be friendly rivalry or do you think
there's actually serious hostility
between England and Australia on the
pitch tomorrow
look to be honest I mean there's going
to be a bit of I think it's more
friendly rivalry I know that the girls
you know the matildas are desperate to
get their hands in some silverware it's
been a long time coming we've always
just come so close now this is the
furthest we've ever come
um you know I did manage to go to an
England game myself and there's still
some passionate English here um over in
Australia that support the Lioness I
know they're a big public figure like
it's going to be a big Clash
unfortunately we're probably going to
dominate the ticket sales I believe so
it's going to be a friendly rivalry a
lot of the girls play against each other
in the WSL
um so you know there's no one familiar
territory there there's no unfamiliar
faces so
um definitely probably our biggest game
to date ever so I'm just really looking
forward to see how it pans out I agree
you're probably going to dominate ticket
sales but we'll be watching here from
England and the UK and I know people
around the world will be as well peers
has been watching from the US tweeting
about it endlessly Leanne what is the
pressure like going to play a team in
its home stadium like that you've played
50 caps for England yeah I've painted
World Cup so the last time we reached
this moment was when in 2015 and we
unfortunately lost to Japan but I think
the Lioness is now after having that
little bit of taste of silverware last
summer I think you can see against
Colombia at the end of the game they
weren't celebrating they were probably
focusing you could see no one was really
running around the field they weren't
really focused on all the fans and the
music focused on the next game and the
challenge that was ahead and I did this
game against Australia with sort of
foregone conclusion you know I don't
want to be that typical English person
every time we get to a World Cup we
think we're going to win you know we
haven't won anything since 1966 a World
Cup so you know with regards to that
it's always going to be difficult but
what I would say you know along with
what we were saying before there's a lot
of these players that played at WSL and
a lot of these guys are familiar with
each other and I think that'll be
something that will friendly rivalry but
I agree it's a massive game for one it's
gonna be a good one but both of you
thanks so much unfortunately that is all
we've got time for whatever you're up to
tonight make sure it's uncensored good
night
[Music]
thank you
good evening I'm Peters Morgan
uncensored in New York City King peers
and King cute I think it's only one for
one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail not working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war but he's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for what appears to be
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better Princess of Wales because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal it does